I got Eve had issues with you brother I  her first our relationship was  complicated it was all my fault his  brother  Isaac's been dead for over a year but I  never saw his body now I have a  situation I know it sounds crazy he's at  my house right now with Sam I just can't  not hear you here we thought you were  dead  maybe I was  new we've got the perfect life here  don't you pee bro Isaac you're bleeding  [Music]  my brother's not in a good way I don't  know what he got himself mixed up go  okay it seemed different  I think something for Isaac oh are you  certain it's him I'm hearing things I'm  seeing things faces what are you doing  demons they're coming after me because  of us Jake what is going on do you think  I'm making this up the only thing that  burns in hell they're all in order it  was the part of yourself  refuses to let go  you will see bevels tearing in your life  apart  you